Let's continue our investigation by looking at some variables
that are highly correlated. This time we'll look at the
number of likes users received from friends on the
desktop version on the site. This is the ww likes
received. We'll compare this variable to the total number
of likes users received which is the likes received variable.
Now you could of course get likes received through the
mobile version but we're not going to look at that here.
So now I'm going to hand it off to you. I want you
to create a scatter plot of this variable versus this variable and it should
make sense that likes received should be higher than ww likes received. Since
some of the likes may be coming from other sources, either mobile or unknown.